nate tonight electric daisy carnival
going to open its gates to hundreds of
thousands of edm lovers many of those
attendees are touching down at reed
international airport for the three-day
festival right now and that's where we
find mary jane bellies and veritate
how's it looking over there is it busy
well heather i would say right now it's
pretty steady here and you know as
festival goers arrive at the airport
well the party is just getting started
now djs are playing music welcoming
attendees not only as they get off the
plane but at baggage claim too tonight
is the first night of edc and you can
see the excitement through the crowds
aside from seeing their favorite djs
some attendees i spoke with say it's not
only their first time going to edc but
their first time coming to las vegas
festival goers are more than ready to
take on the weekend
i literally get just walking around and
seeing everyone be happy together
and like even the facebook group
everyone's been talking so much and just
like sharing their experiences being
really nice like with a good set of
people and that's like the exciting part
for me
yeah and also on top of that like just
staying on the strip i feel like will be
really fun with my friends it's been the
only event i've been looking forward to
because i mean i really wanted to go to
vegas and i wanted to go to a fun event
so it's kind of best of both worlds
if you're headed out to edc this weekend
there are prohibited items no drugs
outside food or alcohol no glass cans
cups or coolers no large backpacks or
purses you are permitted to bring
reusable water bottles as hydration
stations are set up throughout the
festival grounds now safety is very
important at this event medical staff as
well as ground control will be on hand
and it's recommended that you also have
a plan in place in case you get
separated from your friends reporting at
reed international airport mary jane
villeza live local now